Speaker 1: Welcome everybody. I have to
start with some really crazy things today.
The first thing is the next
kind of chapter in the martyrdom
and lionized version of Kyle Rittenhouse. Now
I'm not going to retell you the entire Kyle Kyle
Rittenhouse story, but Kyle Rittenhouse was 17
years old when he went to Kenosha, Wisconsin,
with a firearm and he killed two people,
shot a third, claimed self-defense and was
Speaker 2: acquitted, found not guilty.
Speaker 1: As I said that based on how these
laws are written, that not guilty verdict
is is not really the issue here. It's a
Kyle's presence there being emblematic of so many
of the things wrong with the country. Gun culture,
education, parenting, et cetera. And one of
Speaker 2: the
Speaker 1: concerns we knew what was going to
happen was that Kyle Rittenhouse was going to
be made a hero. He got an interview with
Tucker Carlson with a hero's welcome. He
got to meet Trump, etc. This is now
taking on an even more insane tone.
Speaker 2: There is a new
Speaker 1: series about Kyle Rittenhouse
Speaker 2: produced with Tucker
Speaker 1: Carlson hosting and narrating.
It's on Fox Nation. Fox Nation is a Fox News kind
of like offshoot that includes rehabilitating the
program cops, so it kind of gives you a sense
of the type of content that they produce.
Speaker 2: And it's like
Speaker 1: a bizarre reality show made to
Speaker 2: make him look like a complete
Speaker 1: and total hero. So check out
just like a little clip of this
and just the entire vibe, it's
Speaker 2: all completely insane.
Speaker 1: Look at this.
Speaker 3: Al Rittenhouse Oh, Kyle Rittenhouse,
so nice to meet you. Good to meet you. I can't
believe you're here and have your show.
Well, we're fans of yours, as you know.
Speaker 1: Yeah, yep, that's me. You're probably
wondering how I ended up in this situation.
Speaker 3: For most Americans, Kyle Rittenhouse
is more meme than man. But in real life,
Rittenhouse is a working class kid
from the least privileged sector
Speaker 2: of our society. So, yeah.
Speaker 1: As I've said, first of all, who's
the audience for this right, that's one thing
to think about, like we're watching it as a goof
and because it's so absurd and because it's
a media story that there is a media outlet
doing this, but there are people who watch this
Speaker 2: seriously and they go,
Speaker 1: Wow, what a
Speaker 2: what a hero. What a great
Speaker 1: kid. He did a great thing
Speaker 2: and remember
he didn't do a great thing.
Speaker 1: He was somewhere he shouldn't have been
with a gun he shouldn't have had. And he caused a
situation in which he feared for his life. I even
would concede he plausibly feared for his life.
And he was acquitted. But we don't celebrate it.
We say, Well, this was a tragedy. It should have
been avoided altogether. The lesson wouldn't be
he's a hero. The lesson would be would have
made sense never to go in the first place.
But this show makes him a hero then.
Speaker 2: And this is just wacky.
Speaker 1: Tucker Carlson, in a direct
to camera sort of thing, explains
that what we he basically uses kind
Speaker 2: of like Bolshevik
Speaker 1: style revolution
as an analogy to the desire
for the imposition of anarchy tyranny in
the United States and links all of this
back to Kyle Rittenhouse. Take a look at this
Speaker 3: tyranny you may have heard the term.
Here's the most straightforward definition it
means anarchy for the people in charge. Tyranny
for the population and a tyranny is a system
in which pedophiles and career criminals are
released from prison by the state to terrorize
the law abiding. Law abiding defend themselves,
they're prosecuted by the state for murder,
smeared by the media as terrorists, arguably
a domestic terrorist. All is corporate sponsored
activist groups burn their country to the ground.
We're seeing this, but we've seen it before
in the years before the Bolshevik Revolution.
Russia was deeply destabilized by crime and chaos.
And that set the stage for the Bolshevik takeover
in the Soviet Union during the great terror
of political dissidents were put on trial for
daring to defend themselves against criminals
in the Soviet Union. You could only use a knife
in self-defense after you'd been stabbed.
Does that sound familiar? The trial of Kyle
Rittenhouse may be the first anarcho tyrannical
show trial in the United States. It may not
Speaker 2: be the last. So the most
Speaker 1: curious part about that
Speaker 2: is the
Speaker 1: analysis is
completely bogus analysis. It's flaccid in every
in every way. It's pathetic. It's a wet noodle.
Speaker 2: But do you think
Speaker 1: the audience of this network and of
this show that's watching it in a serious way
Speaker 2: knows about Bolshevism or
Speaker 1: anarcho tyranny? I mean, seriously,
like even this is a perfect example of,
you know, people, you ask them, Do you
read history? They go, Yeah, I read Bill
Speaker 2: O'Reilly's history books like, OK,
Speaker 1: who is the audience here?
Speaker 2: And it's all
Speaker 1: wacky, and it's meant specifically
to inspire a certain type of person
Speaker 2: to accept without
Speaker 1: questioning what Tucker is telling
you. And of course, except that Kyle Rittenhouse
is a hero, truly just bizarre
stuff. Here's a clip from the end.
Speaker 2: And in this scene,
Speaker 1: they put Kyle Rittenhouse like,
it's so overproduced. They have Kyle Rittenhouse
wearing a suit on a beach, and Tucker celebrates
that Kyle Rittenhouse is moving to Florida, which
is a free state, and also frames Rittenhouse as a
victim who now is going to have to deal
with all this for the rest of his life.
Speaker 3: Kyle Rittenhouse wanted to move
to the paradise of Florida to the Free State.
Now he has his chance. Even so, he will never
have the luxury of living a normal life.
I'll never be able to erase the slander and stigma
laid on him, by the media and by his prosecution.
Those are the consequences of the trial of Kyle.
Unidentified: The next time it could be you.
Speaker 1: I like how Tucker
says you could be next. You know,
one way to avoid being the next Kyle Rittenhouse
is don't go to locations of unrest with firearms,
then you're not going to be the next Kyle
Rittenhouse. Now, of course, Tucker would say,
Well, no, there's a million other ways in which
you could be victimized by the system the way
he was. But what an overproduced sham. And my
prediction is that this show will do really
well with the Fox Nation audience. So this
is why we said they would make him a hero.
Speaker 2: They're making him a hero. They're
making him a martyr. They're making him a sage.
And it is completely and
Speaker 1: totally
Speaker 2: disgusting. But
we knew it would happen.